this metal is about as close to Magic as
it is possible to find in nature I just
don't get it
it can adjust its arrangement of atoms
to return to some predefined shape but
it also converts between mechanical and
thermal energy and it can stretch up to
30 times more than an ordinary metal and
still spring back to its original size I
can feel it in my hands shrinking back
because of these unique properties it's
being used in everything from medical
devices to toys to bulletproof bike
tires
and it's allowing NASA to reinvent the
wheel for space exploration
this is the bones of the bones of the
tire the bones of the tire is a slinky
so basically this is a the slinky
applied to the rim you just wrapped a
slinky around a rim yeah it doesn't get
any simpler than that right here is a a
bicycle that has slinkies inside a
polymer if you look inside there this
tire does not require air pressure to
work the structure and shock absorption
are all provided by that metal Slinky so
that's like around 100 PSI or what a
normal road bike would feel like yeah
which means you should be able to
puncture it with no loss of performance
so we're gonna drive it over a bed of
nails but first we'll test a traditional
pneumatic tire just to make sure these
nails are Sharp
foreign
another puncture another flat tire this
one kind of expected so now I'm going to
put these airless tires to the test
driving over the same bed of nails
here we go
[Applause]
I heard a lot of Pops I must have hit
some nails
I don't feel anything different
still rides well
I'm gonna get up some speed
that's definitely a nail I think the
nail broke in it that's what it looks
like yeah the Nail's in the tire
we're now going to try to shoot a bullet
into the tire and see what happens three
two one
there it is there it is
wow it's just it's a really clean shot
straight through yep barely even see the
mark on the tire looks like this one
actually hit the
hit the alloy yep it does to me yeah
that's what it feels like you can see we
spliced off some of the bullet before we
even got the cardboard
how's it ride
yeah no problems
bulletproof bicycle
this bulletproof bike tire actually
comes out of NASA's Research into making
wheels for space missions
[Music]
it is really hard to make good wheels
for other planets I mean a lot of the
places we want to send Rovers to there
is no or very low atmospheric pressure
we can't use rubber pneumatic tires
because of the extreme conditions on the
moon and Mars there's no confining
pressure outside of it it can basically
explode besides with temperatures
dropping to extreme lows rubber becomes
brittle If This Were
a flagpole the temperature facing the
sun would be 250 degrees Fahrenheit
above zero in the shadow is 250 degrees
below zero Let's uh put some rubber on
the moon negative 90 is the glass
transition temperature it's when the
polymer goes from being flexible to a
rigid element this is what happens when
you dip rubber in liquid nitrogen
[Music]
that's why you can't send rubber to the
Moon
this is why almost all the wheels used
for exploring other planets have been
made of hard metal this is actually a
spare for the Curiosity Rover made out
of aluminum a single Billet that gets
machined down so you don't have to worry
about Fasteners or welds or anything
like that they could potentially be a
failure point but with it being so
expensive to launch matter into space
the wheels have to be as lightweight as
possible it's it's light-ish but it's
still heavy to meet those Mass
limitations they made this skin 0.7
millimeters thick thinner than a credit
card yep these structural members here
which we also call grousers they're
there to give the wheel strength but
also help grab onto obstacles and and
help grab the soil the problem is that
because this rubber is so large and
heavy and the terrain is just so
aggressive and nasty they're actually
seeing much higher Peak loads kind of
focused on areas between these grousers
than what was predicted and this is the
actual condition of the wheels on Mars
right now and as you can see I've got
big holes and cracks where those skin
where the skin was now the wheel still
operates hasn't immobilized the Rover
it's still going to complete its Mission
but it does affect where it can go and
how how efficient it is
when you apply a force to a material
that is known as a stress and what
you're really doing is tugging on all
the atoms inside the object and as a
result their spacing changes a little
bit and so the material deforms for
example if you pull on an object it will
get slightly longer and the per unit
change in length is called strain now
for most materials under low stresses
strain is directly proportional to the
stress applied and the more you stress
it the more it stretches and the
material is elastic if you remove the
stress the object goes back to its
original size so no atoms have moved
around and no bonds have been broken or
formed you've just made them Flex when
you apply that stress but if the stress
applied exceeds the yield strength of
the material whether this strain is so
great that the atoms can't maintain
their positions relative to each other
defects called Edge dislocations can
move through the material the atoms are
actually rearranging themselves and so
the deformation is not reversible it's
plastic deformation so the object won't
go back to its original shape when the
stress is removed if enough stress is
applied the material can completely
fracture
in the worst case scenario this results
in holes like in the Mars rover Wheels
which reduce their performance and
ultimately could jeopardize the mission
ordinary metals can withstand a strain
of only around 0.3 to 0.8 percent
elastically any more than that and they
undergo plastic deformation so they
won't return to their original shape
ultimately they could even fracture
all right
King tip and stretched it and that's why
every component of a space vehicle is
designed never to stretch more than that
0.3 to 0.8 percent but that's a
significant limitation
there is a different type of wheel that
NASA has tried in space which are those
on the Apollo lunar roving vehicle or
lrv that particular structure that they
built is something that we call
pantograph all it is is it's a set of
wires that have been over under over
under woven and this this on the surface
here to get grip also to strengthen it's
primarily to ensure that the tire does
not sink into the ground so they did
some studies with these tread strips to
figure out how much coverage they needed
and so they they found out that roughly
50 percent was enough to keep the tire
kind of floating on the surface and
still maintain that flexibility the
lunar roving vehicle Wheels worked well
for the short distance Journeys traveled
on the Moon I mean the farthest this
vehicle ever went was 36 kilometers but
still these wheels needed to be designed
to minimize plastic deformation of the
steel mesh and so they put this internal
structure inside there we call it a bump
stop so as they hit a bump and this is
deformed when it hits that it's stops
the deformation to keep it just below
that proportional limit where they would
induce plasticity
this wheel was good enough for the short
Apollo missions but for longer Journeys
a bump stop won't be enough to prevent
plastic deformation building up over
time mesh steel wheels have been tried
on Earth but their performance does
degrade over time this was the Mars
steel Spring tire we we made and drove
on that same test rig and there's no
fracture but you see a lot of permanent
deformation there what we need is a
material that is strong and durable like
steel but which can endure much more
strain without deforming permanently
and that is where this stuff comes in
[Music]
in 1961 the naval Ordnance laboratory
was doing experiments with different
Alloys involving nickel and titanium
sample that had been repeatedly worked
heated and cooled was shown to one of
the associate technical directors who
just happened to be a pipe smoker so he
decided to see what the sample would do
if he applied a bit of heat from his
lighter and when he did that he found
that the material changed shape this
shocked everyone and led to more
investigations into the material which
became known as nitinol for its
components nickel and titanium and for
the naval Ordnance laboratory where it
was discovered
so why did nitinol change shape
It's really because the Ally can undergo
a phase change in the solid state
in heated nitinol the atoms are arranged
in a cubic lattice Arrangement and this
phase is known as austenite but upon
cooling the atoms ease into a form known
as twinned martensite
it's a Messier lower symmetry
arrangement of the atoms and in this
phase you can apply stress to the
material and deform it but unlike in an
ordinary metal this deformation is not
causing bonds between atom is to break
and Edge dislocations moving throughout
the material now in this case the
crystal structure is changing once again
to a d-twined form of martensite and now
when you heat it back up the material
goes from martensite back to being
austenite which means all the atoms go
back to their original locations and so
the material returns to its original
shape we can basically set this shape as
the parent known memory shape that's why
we call it shape memory I can stretch
this out I can if I cooled it down I
could stretch it out even more but as
soon as I heat it back up
it'll remember that original apparent
shape
[Music]
and that's why nitinol is considered a
shape memory alloy
this shape is set at high temperature
when the material is in the austenite
phase then as the material is cooled
down it undergoes a phase transition
into twinned martensite if stress is now
applied to the material in this phase it
can be extensively deformed by changing
the crystal structure into detwinned
martensite when the stress is released
most of that deformation remains but
when the sample is heated the atoms
return to the austenite phase which
Returns the material to its original
shape
[Music]
it's like you're barely in the water
yeah and it just as fast as you can
conduct heat to it or get heat away from
it
whoa
I mean that's cool
this is the property of night null that
most people are aware of and one that
makes it useful for a lot of
applications so that's a stint they
slightly cool these down
right below to Martin's site and then
they crush it or elongate it so you can
see it gets real thin and then they put
in a catheter and that catheter goes
through the body to the place where they
want to deploy the stent and then upon
deploying it it bounces right back
increasing that outer diameter and
opening that artery nitinol is
absolutely perfect for that shape memory
Alloys can actually generate significant
forces when they're heated which means
they can also be used as actuators
you're going to see a huge amount of
force and stress build up in the wire
which we can see with here with how much
it's pulling
six pans seven
you really see it Contracting there
13 15 16 17.
20 pounds
oh it's lifting it that's about 90
Newtons of force
[Music]
scientists have even used shape memory
Alloys to fracture a rock
cheap memory Alloys are being
investigated for use in aviation I made
a video before about Vortex generators
which are these little fins that stick
up out of the wing of a plane to trip
the airflow into turbulence this is
important for takeoff and Landing to
keep the flow attached to the wings so
you don't stall but when you're up at
cruise and you don't need need those
vortices being generated you want these
to Stow because they're a drag penalty
as the plane just climbs from takeoff to
cruise we go from some temperature on
the ground to something close to minus
50 minus 60c at Cruz the alloy is
designed in between those so that we can
just take advantage of the ambient
temperature change that happens in the
environment when we cool this one down
no controller no operator and autonomous
at least stays flat the temperature at
which the material transitions between
austinite and martensite can be tuned to
be anywhere between
-150 to positive 350 degrees Celsius
this is done by changing the ratio of
the elements and using different heat
treatments and then as that would heat
back up coming into landing
comes right back up
this principle has been extended to
operate the main flaps on an aircraft
now the heating and cooling is not
passive but controlled by a heating
element so we've done demonstrations
where you have a 737 aircraft and no
hydraulic actuators on the wing box all
we have is a shuttle mechanism that's
driven by two tubes and nitinol and
we've driven those ailerons and flap
elements on the wing box of a 737 in
Flight 60 degrees flap angle down 30
degrees flat angle up just by Heating
and Cooling two tubes of nitinol
replaces all the hydraulics
the shape memory effect is the main
thing people know about materials like
nitinol but they have another unique
property which makes them ideal for
making durable wheels and you're just
going to take it and you're going to
Loop it a couple times around your hand
like that and you're just going to pull
on that wire and feel six to eight
percent strain in a piece of metal oh
that's really weird that's six to eight
percent strain which you can't do in
other wires right but what's weird about
it is that it feels a little crunchy it
feels because you're feeling all of the
reorientations oh so weird so cool
though right yes very cool
foreign
can you hear that yeah
yeah how weird that pinging is 20.
shape memory Alloys can stretch up to
eight percent of their length and still
spring back to their original size this
property is known as super elasticity or
pseudo-elasticity but they're kind of
misnomers because the material is not
actually operating in its elastic regime
what's actually happening is that this
Knight null is in the austenite phase
it's transition temperature is lower
than room temperature but by applying a
stress even with no temperature change
you can force the crystal structure to
change from austenite into detwind
martensite and this rearrangement allows
the nitinol to deform by that eight
percent and still it'll snap back to its
original configuration once the stress
is removed and the atoms return to the
austenite phase
that sound you're hearing is the
material undergoing a stress-induced
phase change in the solid state if you
want to think about it on a stress
strain curve now this transformation is
occurring entirely above the martensite
transition temperature so the material
starts off in the austenite phase and
then the applied stress is what induces
the phase change from austenite to
d-twined martensite and when that stress
is removed the atoms spring back to the
austenite phase and so the material goes
back to its original size and shape
If This Were a normal tube I would bend
it to here and it would plasticize if it
was a brass tube which you know has a
plastic buckling mode it would go like
this and it would actually Buckle the
wall I would never take my hands and
bend them like this
and have it completely return to shade
at the bend the night null is
transforming from austenite to
martensite and back when we go from the
higher
symmetry phase the austenite to the
lower symmetry daughter phase which one
is it exothermic or endothermic I feel
like that should be
exothermic good job Science Guy
if you were to put your hand around this
tube you'll actually feel
the heat energy the enthalpy of that
transformation evolving as heat you
ready yep
oh yeah that's real hot
oh
that actually is like burning like I
can't keep my hand oh keep your hand on
it it won't burn it when the stress is
removed and the material goes back to
being austenite that phase change is
endothermic it absorbs heat
[Laughter]
right
it's like you could use that for a
refrigerator so the it's exactly right
so another area where these materials
are being applied is in a field called
elastoklorex where we use this
transformation to do things like
equivalent to heat pumping I want to
shoot this with our thermal camera we
got a flare with us
how's that
this dissipation potential can act a
little bit like the dissipation in the
shock absorber right so the tire itself
could actually perform some of that
dissipation potential on its own it
almost acts as a damper right to get rid
of that energy loss so then your your
tire actually has a potential of
becoming a complete suspension system
which obviously really simplifies
building vehicles for for space the
original Tire when I put load on it okay
you can see I'm only transferring a load
from the footprint to this little
section of the tire right by tying
these this Bump Stop element to here
when I go through a footprint you can
see now I'm transferring load 360
Degrees around the tire
right by doing that I have now increased
my load carrying capacity significantly
without adding any more mass
so to make a tire out of shape memory
alloy they weave nitinol Springs
together into a mesh it's a pretty
tedious and time consuming process
so you're going to take it like so yep
both ends no and I'll take it no you're
right now yeah and screw it in oh my
goodness
are you kidding me
is this what you do every day
684 times
per timer
but will these wheels work on Rovers on
the moon and Mars
well they test the wheels extensively on
a rotating Carousel of different terrain
types from Sand to small rocks to bigger
rocks so the train endurance rig
basically consists of a circular
Carousel that is independently driven
the wheel tire assembly is also
independently driven so we can create a
force slip condition so we can drive
with zero slip
and this is about how slow a Mars Rover
would be traveling average speed is
about 6.7 centimeters per second that's
a nominal speed they don't go too fast
all right I'm gonna go walk on simulated
Moon regular
it looks like beach
and it feels like beach this side is
meant to simulate the surface of the
Moon and this side is meant to be the
surface of Mars
it is uh very sinky sand
wheel is rolling along rolling along
it's a rock and I'm just am I pushing
into it or do I want to get it on top
it's like it on top and just put all
your body weight onto it
that's basically my full weight on it
the Sheep memory alloy is strong enough
to support the weight of the vehicle or
vehicle and crew but it's also
incredibly flexible so it can deform up
to eight percent without being
permanently damaged and that's what's
needed for long space missions
so that's a pretty good amount of
deformation right that's a great amount
of deformation and still not Beyond
eight percent
it's so gooey just walking back to the
car after the beach
tricky for a Rover right but these tires
won't just be for space they're also
looking at terrestrial applications
most aircraft the tires on this aircraft
they have to be pressurized to really
really high pressurizations 300 400 PSI
not the conventional 30 to 60 PSI you do
in a car truck tire right we have issues
where at those huge pressurizations they
can explode the other construct is is
maintenance right so if I'm a pneumatic
tire and I'm relying on that pneumatics
for the performance of the system I have
to always be checking the air pressure
to make sure that I'm at the right
inflation pressure so that I'm not
burning too much fuel or I'm not at a
place where I could potentially pop a
tire because of the loads by going to a
structural system that doesn't rely on
air and is designed specifically for the
application all those things go away
they've tested one on a Jeep since it
doesn't rely on pressurized air for
support you just can't get a flat tire
plus it can ever be under inflated which
significantly improves fuel economy with
a metal that works like magic you can
make airless tires that will take us
off-road on road into the air and across
other worlds
[Applause]
NASA's night and all tires are designed
to last the entire lifetime of a rover
mission even on a rough terrain of Mars
but here on Earth few products last a
lifetime from bike tires to phones to
toothbrushes pretty much everything
wears out but with hints and shaving the
sponsor of this video you may never need
to buy another razor again in your life
Henson actually came out of an aerospace
machine shop that built parts for the
Mars rover and the ISS so they are
experts in precise high quality work if
the temperature to manufacture their
Rover parts changed as little as one
degree they have to scrap the entire
piece and that sort of precision is
overlooked by most razor manufacturers
in a typical razor the blades flex and
bend when they make contact with the
skin and this movement causes micro Cuts
leading to skin irritation and razor
bumps to many people this is just an
inevitable part of Shaving but it
doesn't need to be you want advice about
a good razor
trust a guy with a beard
this is Henson's al-13 razor it's so
precise that the blade extends past the
shave plane by exactly
.0013 inches that's less than the width
of a human hair the blade is also
securely fastened at exactly 30 degrees
leaving almost zero blade Flex for a
smoother and cleaner shave this razor is
designed to last a lifetime and its
standard double edge blades cost only
around 10 cents each which means the
cost of ownership for an al-13 razor
ends up lower than most cartridge or
electric razors after only two years and
besides price considerations having one
razor for the rest of your life is both
more convenient and better for the
planet so if you want one Aerospace
quality razor to last the rest of your
life go to hensonshaving.com veritasium
and enter code veritasium for 100 free
blades with a purchase of a razor that's
two to four years worth of blades on me
make sure to add both the razor and the
blades to your cart for the code to take
effect so I want to thank Henson shaving
for sponsoring this video and I want to
thank you for watching